mein thema ist heute abend der deutsche
freedom day sei eine farce was ich damit
meine während andere eu länder öffnen
kriechen wir noch fünf wochen der
freiheit entgegen pünktlich zum morgigen
corona gipfel mit den länderchefs hat
das kanzleramt einen ersten fahrplan für
das ende der korona maßnahmen vorgelegt
ab vierten märz sollen restaurants
hotels die dreijährige gelten klingt
erst mal gut am 20 märz soll dann der
folie modell sein es sollen alle
tiefgreifenden schutz maßnahmen fallen
aber die maske soll weiterhin den
innenräumen brüsten und bahn getragen
werden was ist das für ein film day für
die kinder ist es noch schlimmer eine
welt recherche ergab dass außer
schleswig holstein bislang nur
rheinland-pfalz und sachsen-anhalt ein
mögliches ende der masken für kinder
schüler platz auf welcher grundlage
sollen die kinder noch länger mit dieser
unsäglichen maske in der schule sitzen
die massen fließen muss endlich fallen
und das für alle und wir müssen meiner
meinung nach sofort öffnen ich hoffe
dass die deutsche politik sich wir sind
wir beim frieden nicht wieder den
deutschen kroner sonderweg hinlegen ja
da gebe ich ihnen völlig recht frau
schenkt das ist auch so man sieht dass
in anderen ländern es ist ja nicht ein
anderes virus was wir hier haben es
anderen denn das ist nicht hier
ansteckender das sind jetzt in der zeit
von omikron das ist eine variante die
doch deutlich weniger schwer wiegendes
als die bisherigen und da gibt es keinen
rationalen grund zu zögern und das nicht
dass nicht sie sich dieses schrittweise
vorgehensweise hat eigentlich keine
rationale begründung auch aus meiner
sicht
jetzt haben wir den film der ja das ist
ja so ein erst mal auf dem weg dahin
eigentlich ein ja bummel weg den wir
einschlagen schnecken weg und ich glaube
den punkt die du auch gemacht hat mit
den masken und der masken pflicht für
kinder ich hatte das vergnügen auch
einmal zweieinhalb stunden die ganze
zeit die maske tragen zu dürfen hat
festgestellt das ist total nervig das
ist total anstrengend wenn wir uns
anschauen wie gering auf der einen seite
die ansteckungsraten ist das eine aber
vor allem auch folgewirkungen bei kinder
sind oder wie gut die eigentlich mit
einer infektion umgehen und wie wir dann
aber zugleich auch sehen was es für
folgen
neben corinna gibt beispielsweise die
dramatischen anstieg von suizidversuchen
im zweiten lockdown beispielsweise bei
kindern dann glaube ich ist der
allerhöchste eisenbahn geboten dann ist
auch die forderung zu sagen die maske
muss weg absolut legitim was wir den
kindern hier in dieser dieser pandemie
an zugemutet haben als wir den
schulkindern zugemutet haben das geht
eigentlich auf keine kuhhaut
ich wollte noch einen moderatorin
erlaubt wenn man
shakespeare zitat aber ich wollte noch
einmal nachfragt und du hast ja kinder
und ich glaube dass wir noch einmal
interessant zu hören wie du das erlebt
hast an denen diese tage diese jahre
also das ist ganz unterschiedlich aber
das was ich erleben konnte gerade wenn
es um
diese wochen und diese monate ging
während zwei von den dreien die
schulpflichtig sind zu hause dann vom
computer sitzen mussten und das war mit
einem möglichen technischen problemen
die man sich auch vorstellen kann die
gab es auch nicht nur bei uns zu hause
habe dann auch bei der lehrerin bei
anderen schulkameraden also da
unterricht zu machen ist eine totale
herausforderung da etwas zu lernen eine
umso größere und dabei noch lustig
fröhlich und den glauben an das gute im
leben auch nicht zu verlieren eine
absolute herausforderung und das ist
glaube ich die größte zumutung die wir
den kindern machen konnten dass wir sie
da haben über monate allein ich sag
jetzt mal einen natürlich meine eltern
betreuung aber alleine vor computern
haben sitzen lassen
ohne dass es irgendwas nebenbei gab und
dass sie jetzt in den klassen sitzen mit
maske und getan wird als wenn die welt
untergeht wenn sie diese maske abnehmen
würden das ist der eigentliche skandal
ein zusätzlich kann man in ein stadion
und die entschuldigung dass ich mal lust
wenn man kann das stadion und die kinder
sehen dass und müssen aber im unterricht
diese maske auf haben und dann müssen
sie zu denken was ist im steigen sind ja
gerade auch wieder limitiert aber ich
glaube wenn man zb eine vip karte hat
dann klappt es dann doch noch
also ich finde erst mal völlig richtig
dass wir endlich dahin kommen dass die
korona maßnahmen aufgehoben werden in
der jetzigen form und das muss auch
deutlich schneller gehen wir sehen ja in
nachbarland dänemark dass da schon die
menschen feiern in diskotheken an den
schulen ist es normal das leben hat sich
weitgehend normalisiert wie vor corona
und man sieht dass die sehr gut damit
umgehen können und sie haben es eben
völlig zu recht gesagt das ist ja da
nicht ein anderes virus als paar
kilometer weiter in deutschland deswegen
völlig richtig würde aber einen
kritischen punkt jedoch anmerken ich
hatte gestern ein wunderbares instagram
live auf einem kanal mit dem hendrik
strikt dem virologen den ich sehr
schätze weil er auch von beginn an immer
wieder nicht nur den virologischen blick
hatte dann war nur dem virologischen
blick hat dann kann man ja sagen alle
bleiben am besten nur zu hause dann
verbreitet sich das virus nicht sondern
auch im gesamtgesellschaftlichen also
welche kollateralschäden gibt es was
bedeutet das für kinder und jugendliche
was bedeutet das fürs sozialleben und
der henrik strikt hatte gestern gesagt
erhält die masken pflicht für sehr
sinnvoll weil die wirklich dazu führt
dass sich das virus nicht stark
verbreitet dass er einen sehr sehr hohen
effekt und die einschränkungen sind ja
vergleichsweise milde und dafür könnte
man in vielen anderen bereichen öffnen
und locker noch nicht
aber die einst die massen krieges
offenbar so einfach umzusetzen dass in
der bundesversammlung die wir nun am
sonntag erlebt haben ist eine
40-minütige masken pause gab die fdp hat
die fdp hat ja aber die hat sich eine
maske pause gönnen von 40 minuten also
offenbar ist dieses maske tragen auch
für erwachsene etwas was sie eigentlich
ungern tun was sie offenbar stört da
gerade passiert das bei kindern am
arbeitsplatz die müssen die ganze diese
masse getragen und das tun sie jetzt
seit bald zwei jahren also es ist jetzt
genau daran was sie sagen das ist in
zwei sachen erstens ist es so dass die
kinder nie die treiber der pandemie
waren das ist wirklich so und die kinder
wenn sie sich erkranken haben auch mit
den schwereren varianten die es am
anfang gab haben die denn selbst in
fällen schwere verläufe gehabt gibt es
ganz wenig todesfälle bei kindern das
hat die bild-zeitung übrigens sehr gut
recherchiert die zweite sache ist
bildung bindung geht vorbildung das
heißt die das kind lernt nicht durch die
informations transfers sondern durch die
beziehung zu den lehrern und den leuten
die unterricht diese idee dann wenn wir
was gutes gelernt haben ist dass dieser
ganze distance-learning wie wir das
sagen nicht so gut funktioniert und dass
dieser dieser emotionale anteil der so
wichtig ist für kinder völlig verloren
geht und wir können überhaupt nicht
ermessen gerade bei den kleinen kindern
wie jetzt die langfristigen
psychologischen auswirkungen sein werden
dessen was wir jetzt die letzten zwei
jahre gemacht haben
die richtung ich frage mich oft auf
welcher grundlage dass mir denn jetzt
überhaupt noch die regierung
vorschreiben dass ich die maske tragen
muss ich zum beispiel hasse die maske
für mich ist es keine kleine
einschränkung immer ein leben das ich
mal mit diesen dingen rumlaufen muss ja
ich bin auch ich freue mich jetzt auch
nicht masken zu tragen dass ich das ist
das schönste überhaupt aber noch mal der
punkt wenn man sich jetzt entscheiden
muss es so sagen okay die staaten
sollten zeit war warum auf welcher
grundlage die hospitalisierung gerade
kann es ja nicht sein ja wobei die kann
natürlich dann teilweise ansteigen also
was der henrik strick zum beispiel
gestern sagte ich war ein ganz
spannendes gespräch deswegen will ich
mal wieder gehen weil ich ja nicht
virologe bin der sagte er geht davon aus
wir müssen noch ein paar wochen an der
masken pflicht festhalten danach kann
man auch die möglicherweise zurücknehmen
weil wir im frühjahr sommer natürlich
deutlich geringere zahl namen als im
herbst aber er geht auch davon aus dass
wir im nächsten herbst winter
möglicherweise auch wieder masken tragen
müssen weil die masse nehmen sehr hohen
effekt haben und ein vergleichsweise
gering eingriff darstellen als ich
wollte also weiß ich werde noch einmal
den punkt machen weil das glaube ich
ganz wichtig ist dass wir unbedingt
verhindern müssen ist dass wir jetzt
dauerhaft geschlossen fußball stadien
haben in den schulen sie haben eben die
situation beschrieben ich teile das ja
alles dass die gewerbetreibenden
teilweise nur sechs sieben monate im
jahr ihren beruf nachgehen können einige
ja mittlerweile seit über zwei jahren
gar nicht wirklich und da würde ich
immer sagen wenn ist dann die maske uns
alles andere sichert kann man daran
zumindest teilweise noch festhalten im
idealfall haben wir aber bald auch gar
keine masken pflicht werden aber die
maske die maske schützt nur wenn die
richtig also rigoros getragen wird wenn
sie richtig angepasst wird und dann nur
ein bisschen also die die die datenlage
für das tragen einer maske wie das im
alltag passiert ist mehr als dünn also
und das würde ich gerne da sagte also da
haben mir jetzt die virologen was
anderes gesagt ja selber keinen forscher
der studie erstellt hat aber die sagten
also der effekt von massa sehr sehr hoch
also meinerseits selbstschutz angeht
andererseits auch was weitergabe des
virus angeht daher würde ich klar ist
dass jetzt nicht das hauptthema auf das
wir uns fokussieren heute in der bild
zeitung ich habe ja auch dazu stellung
genommen im sportteil war ja auch die
diskussion wie ausgelastet können die
fußballstadien sein und da werde ich
immer der meinung die fußballstadion die
müssen jetzt voll auslasten oder
zumindest voller oder aber da müssen wir
jetzt wirklich dabei diskutieren dh die
kinder sollen weiter sechs stunden am
tag sie bleibt die geschichte sein und
in spanien wollen wir beim öffnen ich
meine das habe ich so nicht gesagt und
gemeint aber das ist die frage ich habe
also wenn es sinn für den wert und die
das gewerbe wird geöffnet die stadien
auch über die kinder tragen weiter maske
das kann doch das passt doch nicht nur
ein moment ich bin ich bin der meinung
also das habe ich auch gesagt auch in
den diskussionen mit virologen in den
letzten tagen wie gesagt habe also
erwachsene gehen ins restaurant die
müssen die maske kurz tragen auf dem weg
zum platz setzen sich hin teilweise mit
zehn leuten können die abnehmen fröhlich
was trinken und essen und die kinder
fünf sechs sieben stunden müssen was
getragen das finde ich geht auch nicht
das heißt wenn da so abstände
eingehalten werden wie in restaurants
oder hygienische standards gelten finde
ich sollte noch die kinder keine maske
auf den platz tragen müssen so das finde
ich schon deswegen unterstütze ich das
aber wenn man jetzt sagt okay man hat im
restaurant für 30 meter die maske auf
oder an den schulen kurz für fünf bis
zehn minuten und dafür sorgen wir dafür
dass es nicht so locker um maßnahmen
kommt und wir als crooner wir uns
einigermaßen im griff haben könnte ich
mich in der abwägung noch damit
zufrieden dann wissen ja dass die maske
das den mund verdeckt aus verschiedenen
gründen sie haben professor existiert
aber wir wissen auch dass gerade bei
jungen schülern es extrem wichtig ist
dass sie sehen wie ihr neuer kein lehrer
spricht beispielsweise weil man das am
natürlich dann mit artikuliert wenn es
um fremdsprachen englisch französisch
ist es auch wieder extrem wichtig dass
man da nicht jemand vor sich sitzen hat
er eine maske trägt sondern dass man das
auch sieht wie wird der grund höherer
und sie bewegt sich der wundert ja hört
wir haben sie auch das ist natürlich
durch die maske auch nicht immer gegeben
also wir haben auch da
bei den möglicherweise wirklich dann
auch positiven effekten wie sie es
gerade beschrieben haben natürlich
gleichzeitig extrem negative effekte und
wir müssen da und das meine ich aus dem
tiefsten herzen meiner seele extrem
schnell zurück zu einer normalität
kommen wir kriegen sonst eine generation
von schülerinnen und schülern die
wirklich zurückbleiben stimmung war ein
ganz ganz vielen punkten denn so eine
maske ist mehr als das sie nur einfach
ich bin eigentlich wollte hier ein
falscher eindruck entsteht ich bin ja
nicht dafür dass der jugendliche zwölf
stunden nur maske tragen ich hab immer
selber auch als einer der ersten in der
debatte darauf hingewiesen welche folgen
corona auch gerade für kinder und
jugendliche hat und habe immer gesagt
gerade die müssen in der debatte stärker
berücksichtigt werden mir ging es jetzt
darum wenn man sagt okay die müssen
vielleicht fünf oder zehn minuten eine
maske tragen es gilt ja für erwachsene
aus so ist ja keine seite nur für kinder
und jugendliche gelten soll und dafür
können sie aber normal zur schule gehen
dann wäre das für mich schon okay da
bleiben beim thema comdirect ihn ich
kann ihnen sagen liebe zuschauer wir
haben uns bei verachtender reaktionen
auf die fahne geschrieben weiter über
die massen pflicht bei schülern zu
diskutieren schicken sie uns auch gerne
ihre erlebnisse von ihren kindern
jederzeit zu ich bleibe weiterhin dabei
dass sich dagegen wenden